hey everyone what's happening you wanna
be thinking wow well you go you're gonna
make a whole youtube channel out of this
things why yes I am you may have heard
from me already that I went to VidCon a
couple weeks ago with some really good
friends and I left feeling so motivated
and inspired and empowered
I met creators that I admire for a long
time got to go to panels and parties and
overall just had such a great time at
VidCon and I think the main thing that I
took away from VidCon was that there's
room on the internet for everyone
including you and me so that's partly
one of the reasons why I decided to make
a youtube channel the other thing is
that I'm really empowered by people like
Simone yecchh in physics girl and the
impact that they have on young women to
pursue careers and an interest in
technology in science and if I could
have that kind of impact on just one
person I think that would be so cool
I've been working in tech for about
three years now at two different
companies and so I thought I'd share
with you today six reasons why I love
being a software engineer number one
innovation is everywhere and it's really
cool I lived in Silicon Valley so I
literally live in the middle of the tech
hub living in the middle of Silicon
Valley and being able to experience how
quickly the innovation is going and how
quickly new things are coming out is
really inspiring number two I think one
of the best things about software
engineering is that you can apply your
skills to anything for instance you can
make health apps that monitor the blood
sugar levels of patients or you can make
educational apps that help teachers
organize their coursework more easily or
you can even make code that gets set up
into space that is so cool
so this actually has a lot to do with
why I went into software engineering at
the career and studied computer science
to begin with I didn't really know what
exactly like what industry that I wanted
to go into but I did want to have the
freedom to be able to choose throughout
my whole career and not limit myself
number three is collaboration where
Deanne Tech actually means that you get
to work with so many different kinds of
people on the daily I get to work with a
product manager who decides what we work
on and why it's important a designer who
decides how is it going to look and how
is it going to feel what a user is
working on it
of course other software engineers who
I'm working with and solving these
problems with as I'm building and also I
get the opportunity to work with data
scientists marketing people support
people it's just so cool to be able to
work with so many different kinds of
people who think in such different ways
and to be able to create a product
together that you can deliver out into
the world
number four is problem-solving so coding
is really just problem-solving so you
have a problem in front of you which is
usually like how do I build this thing
and then you make the code and you
problem-solve through that to build that
thing and one of my favorite things
about software engineering is that you
can spend a lot of time researching the
problem trying out different things
talking about it with other people and
the next thing you know you have a
solution to the problem that you're
working on and sometimes it takes you
know thirty minutes sometimes it takes
three days sometimes it takes a whole
month and that's not to say that
creativity isn't involved in the job
because it's so is the is
problem-solving is not just a matter of
doing formulas and equations and stuff
but it's really thinking creatively
about how to solve the problem that's
right in front of you number five is
that you're always learning so this
actually refers back to number one which
is about innovation because innovation
is literally just about kind of the
invention of new stuff all the time it
kind of goes along with your job as a
software engineer because there's always
new stuff coming out whether it be a new
programming language or a new framework
or a new architecture and so having this
skill of being able to adapt to new
things is really important and that's
something that companies often look for
but in my opinion it's always fun to be
in an area where new things are coming
out all the time because then there's
always something new to like learn and
grab and add to your skill set okay so
my last and final reason why I love
being a software engineer it's probably
my most favorite number six is impact so
because of the nature of code and
electronics and computers and stuff your
code can be on an infinite number of
devices all around the world
and usually if you're building an app or
something you're at least going to reach
thousands ten thousands hundred
thousands sometimes millions of people
and it's really cool to know that what
you're building is
sexing so many people out there and if
you have the chance to meet the people
who you're writing these apps for then
it's an amazing feeling when someone
tells you hey your app has made my life
so much easier
and the other side is that you don't
just have an impact on the people that
you're writing code for but you also
have an impact on your peers around you
it's really awesome to you know help
each other grow as you build something
really cool so that concludes the six
reasons why I love working as a software
engineer it's a really rewarding career
and I've been loving it so far and if
you have any other career related
questions for me about being a software
engineer or being a woman in tech or
anything at all let me know I would love
to answer them I hope this video is
helpful and I'll see you next time have
a good day
[Music]